Herzlich willkommen an der
Landesverteidigungsakademie.
Ich bin Oberst Jürgen Wimmer und leite
hier das Referat Operation. Aus diesem
Grunde möchte ich heute ein paar strategische und
operative Aspekte zur Ukraine-Krise beleuchten.
Ich möchte beginnen mit den Prinzipien
strategischen Handelns. Wie Sie hier sehen:
die klassischen Machtinstrumente eines Akteurs,
das bedeutet Diplomatie, Wirtschaft, Militär und
Information, sind ins Zusammenwirken zu bringen,
um letztendlich strategische Ziele zu erreichen.
Ich möchte einen Blick zurückwerfen auf
das Jahr 1989. Sie sehen hier an der Karte
in blau dargestellt die NATO und in
Rot dargestellt den Warschauer Pakt.
Schauen wir ins Jahr 2022, sehen Sie
hier die Linie der NATO-Osterweiterung.
Auf einen weiteren Klick stelle ich nochdas Gebiet der Ukraine dar. Sie sehen anhand
dieser Darstellung einen großen Gebietsverlust
der ehemaligen Sowjetunion. Sie sehen hier die
Kernaussage aus einer Militärzeitschrift aus
den USA, die bereits im Dezember Aussagen, die
im Herbst getroffen wurden, darstellt aus der
Sicht Russlands und zwar die Angst vor einer
NATO-Osterweiterung und der absolute Wille, die
Ukraine davon abzuhalten, Teil der NATO zu werden.
Eine Rede Putins vom Tag vor dem Angriff auf
die Ukraine. Ich habe hier ein paar Kernaussagen
dieses russischen Narratives dargestellt.
Einerseits, dass die Ukraine fixer Bestandteil
der russischen Geschichte, Kultur
und auch des geistigen Raumes ist.
Weiters dass ein Beitritt der Ukraine zur NATO als
eine direkte Bedrohung Russlands gesehen wird.
Dass die russische Bevölkerung
in der Ukraine bedroht ist.
Sowie eine Anerkennung der beiden Gebiete Donezk
und Luhansk. Putin beendet seine Rede damit,
dass er der Ukraine die Verantwortung
für jegliches weitere Blutvergießen gibt.
Sie sehen hier nochmal dargestellt,
anhand der Karte in der Ukraine
diese russischen Kerninteressen: Einerseits
ein Puffer zur NATO-Grenze, andererseits
die strategische Relevanz des
Zugangs zum Schwarzen Meer.
Ich möchte nun eingehen auf die
operativen Umsetzungsmöglichkeiten
dieser strategischen Interessen und konzentriere
mich daher auf den Beitrag des Militärs.
Aus meiner Beurteilung hätte es mehrere
Möglichkeiten gegeben: Eine Minimum-Variante,
das bedeutet die Inbesitznahme der
Separatistengebiete inklusive der
Krim, um den Zugang zum Schwarzen Meer
abzusichern. Eine weitere Variante wäre gewesen:
eine mittelmäßige Ambition, die Ostukraine in
Besitz zu nehmen. Hier hätte sich angeboten:
ein Manöver mit einem Stoß entlang des Dnepr als
trennendes Gelände sowie wiederum die
beiden Separatistengebiete und die Krim.
Als robusteste Variante wäre ein massiver Angriff
eine Möglichkeit gewesen. Nämlich mit einem
Angriff auf Norden, direkt auf die Hauptstadt, mit
einem zentralen Stoß sowie auch mit einem Stoß aus
aus dem Süden, um die ukrainischen Streitkräfte zu
zerschlagen, die Hauptstadt in Besitz zu nehmen,
die Schwarzmeerküste zu haben und somit
Druck auf die Ukraine ausüben zu können.
Auf dieser Darstellung sehen Sie die aktuelle
Lage nach etwa drei Wochen seit Kriegsbeginn.
Wie Sie im Vergleich sehen, hat sich Russland für
diese robusteste Variante entschieden. Sie sehen
auch das Zusammenwirken, durch die Pfeile
grob dargestellt, der Landstreitkräfte
gemeinsam aber auch mit Operationen in der Tiefe,
hauptsächlich durchgeführt durch Luftstreitkräfte,
um militärische Einrichtungen in der
Tiefe zu bekämpfen und somit auch die
Versorgung der kämpfenden Truppen der Ukraine zu
behindern. Was hier ebenfalls dargestellt ist,
in Gelb, diese strichlierte Linie, das ist in etwa
die Linie, in der die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte im Osten verteidigen.
Welche Gefahren gibt es derzeit?
Einerseits durch eine Zusammenführung
der Stöße aus dem Norden sowie aus dem Süden,
diese ukrainischen Kräfte im Osten abzutrennen.
Wie bereits angesprochen, der Dnepr ist
eine sehr trennende Linie mit wenigen
Übergangsmöglichkeiten. Und andererseits Kiew
sowie die anderen großen Städte zu isolieren,
letztendlich einzuschließen und in einem
verlustreichen Häuserkampf weiterzukämpfen.
Was können wir für Folgerungen ziehen? Eine
Folgerung ist auf jeden Fall, sofern vitale
interessen gefährdet sind - aus dieser Sicht,
aus Russland, waren es vitale Interessen -
wird gehandelt. Weiters hat sich der Wandel
langsam aufgebaut, die Eskalation ist aber
blitzartig erfolgt, mit Beginn des Angriffs Ende
Februar. Der konventionelle Krieg in Europa ist
sehr wohl möglich, das hat uns dieses Beispiel
gezeigt, was jahrzehntelang immer wieder zur
Diskussion stand. Und ich möchte auch behaupten,
von einer derzeitigen strategischen Vernunft des
Westens, eine Hand an den Machtinstrumenten
Diplomatie, Wirtschaft aber auch Information,
ist hier der Westen klar überlegen. Ich
komme später nochmal dazu. Eine Deeskalation,
das Spannungsfeld zwischen Hilferufen der
Ukraine, humanitäres Leid, im Spannungsfeld,
im Gegensatz dazu, nicht so offensiv als
Europa zu agieren, insbesondere militärisch,
um keine weitere Eskalation anzufackeln. Weiters
Wechselwirkungen mit der Destabilisierung des
Balkans. Wir kennen die Problematik um die
Abspaltungstendenzen der letzten Jahre
der Republik Srpska aus BosnienHerzegowina
und darüber hinaus die Stellung Serbiens,
die einerseits pro EU sind, andererseits
aber auch sehr wirtschaftlicheund enge
Verflechtungen mit Russland haben und sich
jetzt sehr neutral verhalten.
Auf jeden Fall ein Erwachen Europas
und ein Manifestieren der Bedeutung
der europäischen Sicherheits
und Verteidigungspolitik.
Ich möchte mit einer abschließenden
Bewertung, einer sehr kurzen, abschließen,
nach einem Ampelsystem und komme wiederum zurück
auf das Grundprinzip strategischen Handels.
Im Bereich der Diplomatie, kann man sagen, aus
russischer Sicht, derzeit eine sehr schwierige
Lage. Europa ist geeinter denn je und Russland
ist eigentlich von der Masse der Welt diplomatisch isoliert.
Im Bereich der Information,
zumindest in westlichen Medien,
kann man sagen, hat auf jeden Fall die Ukraine
Oberhand und die Weltmeinung ist auf Seiten
der Ukraine. Im Bereich der Wirtschaft, kann
man sagen,
es hat solche Sanktionen, wie es sie derzeit
gegen Russland gibt, eigentlich noch nie
gegeben und somit komme ich zum Militär. Sie
sehen hier ein Farbspiel aus Grün und Orange,
nach dem Ampelsystem. Ich würde sagen,
Russland hat nach wie vor die Initiative,
es wurde aber insbesondere der Wehrwille der
Ukraine unterschätzt und es tragen wahrscheinlich
auch noch einige andere Faktoren dazu bei. Ich
komme zur strategischen Interessensumsetzung
Russlands. Aus meiner Sicht hat es hier eine
Überschätzung oder Fehleinschätzung
gegeben, was letztendlich dazu führt, dass die
letzte Option derzeit die militärische ist,
die aus jetziger Sicht doch noch einige Zeit
dauern wird. Ich danke für die Aufmerksamkeit.